ass ass in crack stars Michael
Fassbender and is based off of the very
well-known Assassin's Creed video games
I have myself playing a lot of these
games I even reviewed one of them on my
channel and the plot of this movie is
Michael Fassbender has been killed for a
crime through lethal injection he's
revived I guess by this agency who has
technology that allows him to go into
his past to his ancestors body and do
insane amounts of parkour and BASE
jumping with no parachute while he looks
for something these people really need
because they think that if they obtain
this one item they could actually
eliminate violence for mankind and the
way to do that of course is to kill a
bunch of people look I'm a fan of video
games okay but I'm not so much a fan of
video game movies historically they're
awful and I thought maybe with the
inclusion of Michael Fassbender in this
film that we could get one that wasn't
and I was wrong Assassin's Creed is an
awful movie this movie is so poorly made
let's get into the one strengths that a
lot of people are pinpointing about this
film the action sequences look if you're
a fan of the way Olivia or Megaton edits
his films like transporter 3 Columbiana
or taken to or taken 3 well then yeah
you'll probably like the action
sequences in Assassin's Creed if you
like well filmed and beautifully
choreographed action sequences with long
takes then you'll probably hate them in
this film because they're the exact
opposite of that I thought we had
progressed beyond the time where every
action movie was trying to look like a
Bourne film but apparently we're still
in that and once again we have another
shoddy paul greengrass imitation with
action sequences edited with the
intrinsic desire to show everything from
three different angles there's clearly
excellent stunt work on display in this
movie but you never get an opportunity
to soak it in because they're constantly
cutting back and forth to different
shots it's maddening beyond the action
sequences though the story of this film
is incredibly confusing and this is
coming from somebody who's played the
games the movie just doesn't really hold
up and it doesn't make sense
as a script and as a film that has a
plot even as a videogame movie I expect
certain things to
makes sense and the majority of this
movie is just sort of like hey what can
we do well let's just do it does it make
sense no we can use CGI to fix
everything Michael Fassbender and Marion
Cotillard and Jeremy Irons believe it or
not they're all trying but they kind of
just play pale imitations of themselves
they just seem like they're doing their
thing they're in their wheelhouse as a
performer and they're in a film that has
no idea how to utilize their strengths
it's also a heavily sanitized movie the
violence in this movie is very pg-13 and
it's on the wrong side of pg-13 where
you take a movie like Casino Royale that
has really hardcore brutal action
sequences and then you look at this film
that always cuts away whenever anything
happens to a different angle to obscure
what might be a little violent it's
rather annoying especially since all the
games are rated mature there's one scene
in this movie where somebody should be
losing a ton of blood I mean it should
be all over the floor and there's like
this little tiny puddle and it's of
course color corrected to look kind of
black because you don't want to get a
radar that would be bad the primary
audience for the games can't even buy
them unless they're 17 or older why
don't you just make your movie rated R
and forget about the fucking box office
for two seconds it may have been better
there's also a strange logical
inconsistency in this movie beyond the
fact that they take literally like 25
minutes to explain how a guy who's
getting lethal injection all of a sudden
is revived and now he's going into the
past or this weird machine beyond all
that and how incredibly rushed that felt
when he's in this machine it cuts back
and forth between the past and the
present you see him doing these amazing
feats in the past and in the present
he's in this machine and he's mimicking
all these actions but of course they
only ever show him mimicking these
actions when it's something really epic
like jumping or climbing a wall so
they'll show him like climbing the
bricks of this room he's in or something
but I just want to know what occurs when
in the past he's just running in a
straight line in the present day what
does he just run in a circle it makes no
sense they never cut back to him
when he's like on a horse in the past
because then he just be like bouncing up
and down in the president it would look
really stupid guys I'm not going to
waste any more time talking about this
film assassin's creed is exactly what we
all didn't want it to be another
terrible video game movie adaptation
with some actors who are trying and for
that reason I will give assassin's creed
a D I have a lot of videos to work on
right now my best and worst of the year
list some Oscar e-type films I'm going
to be reviewing and a special holiday
themed movie review coming to you
tomorrow that I'm really excited about
and I have been doing a series of video
game hilarious 'ti reviews and you're
going to get a link for some of those in
just a second here I hope you check them
out I reviewed a lot of really funny
stuff guys thank you so much as always
for watching and if you like this you
can click right here and get steppen
eyes
[Applause]
[Music]
you